ثلاثه ايام قضتها حاتان الاسرتان
السودانيتان في رحله شاقه امتدت من
الخرطوم الى مطار فلوج لجنوب السودان
فحادير الطيران العسكري واصوات المدافع
وازيز الرصاص كان كفيلا بدفء المئات من
الاسر الى الفرار من منازلهم
درمان ويعني الضرب شديد يعني الطيران
بيكون هايم بنص النهار بس يعني حاولني انه
نطلع باي طريقه يعني خلينا هم واخواني في
البيت بعد ده كله يعني
حاولنا نطلع والشارع كان يعني بينزلوا
الاولاد يشاكلوا النساوين يشاكلوا فيكم
انتم ماشيين وين
ويشاكلوا المهم يعني حسينا بحاجه دخلنا
هنا حسينا راحه شويه كذا رحاب هارون سيده
سودانيه في اواخر العشرينيات لديها طفلان
اختارت جنوب السودان بسبب قربها من الحدود
مشيره الى انها ستذهب الى جباه التي لا
تعرف انها اي شيء
صعبه شويه عشان تمشي تتحرك من دارفور تمشي
هذه الاوضاع الانسانيه الحرجه تتالى اصوات
السودانيين مطالبه بوقف الاقتتال لان
الشعبه هو من يدفع فاتوره الحرب الدائره
الان بين الجنرلين الدار
ولا ينظر له نظره واحد من الشعب شاب تعبان
قاعد تعاني في الطريق
يعني اذا يبقى ايقاف صوت البنادق هو ما
يتطلع اليه الشعب السوداني خاصه
الفارينه من رصاصها وقذائفها سودانيون
ركمه فرارهم من قذائف الطيران والمدافع
يبدو ان المعاناه لا تزال تلاحقهم حتى في
الدوله الجرح ولكنهم رغم ذلك عبروا عن
سعادتهم لانهم صاروا في اماننا على الاقل
العربيه مطار فلوج جنوب السودان لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات